well let's take a closer look at the
Wagner group the private military
contractor was started by a Russian
businessman evgeny pregosian in 2014.
back then it was very secretive
organization Wagner is partially funded
through its ties to the Kremlin but it
also accepts payment in Gold precious
gems and natural resources like oil and
gas
before Russia's invasion of Ukraine
Wagner stationed about 2 000 fighters in
Libya they've been there since 2019
supporting forces loyal to warlord
Khalifa hafta the group has fought
alongside pro-syrian government forces
since 2015. it also guards oil fields
for the Assad government now for five
years about a thousand Wagner
mercenaries have provided security
against Rebel attacks for the government
in Central African Republic It's
believed Wagner joined mali's
decade-long fight against on groups last
year after France withdrew its troops
so how might this Mutiny affect Russia's
International standing well we're joined
by Marwan kavalan the director of
political studies at the Arab Center for
research and policy studies who's here
with us in the studio everybody knows
the diplomats love stability
at the moment Russia does not have that
stability how is this going to affect
Russia's standing internationally
well uh Rob it's really interesting that
despite all the indicators that about
the growing clocks within the Russian
Elite nobody actually expected that this
was coming so it's really interesting uh
as far as Russia's International
standing is concerned I believe that the
the image of Putin has been shaken by
this event because everybody was
expecting or was looking at Putin as a
song man of Russia he he couldn't be his
power and authority is Undisputed there
might be
cracks here and there amongst the the
division within Russia but Putin is is
is actually in control uh now I think
everybody is questioning the questioning
that and we still need to see actually
if precogen is is alone in this Mutiny
or he's supported by other elements
within the Russian establishment
if that is if that is the case then a
President Putin Authority and power
inside Russia will be very much damaged
I believe even if he emerges as
Victorious from this from this conflict
Azure report has just mentioned
Wagner has been playing a very active
role in several uh conflicts around the
Middle East and in Africa in Syria in
Libya in Mali in Central African
Republic as well as in Sudan some of
these conflicts actually have
now
been more quiet than they used to be in
the past few years especially in Syria
and Libya but in some countries like
Mali and also Sudan we might be seeing
some consequences in Sudan in particular
where similar conflict is taking place
between militia and the regular army
because Wagner is a militia at the end
of the day was created by the Russian
president in order to escape the the
legal consequences of certain actions on
the on the field
in Sudan we have exactly the same we
have we have Indonesia supported by
Wagner we all know that Wagner actually
is supporting the rabbit support
forces of hemeti in Sudan against the
regular army so we still need to see how
that is going to impact the ongoing
conflict in in in Sudan as well as in
Mali as your correspondence was
referring a few minutes a few minutes
ago so we might be seeing some
consequences in certain conflicts in
these in these countries we will we will
be seeing also a weakening uh position
of the Russian president and the
international stage
that will indeed have have a Major
Impact I believe in some conflicts in
the region uh in Syria we might be
seeing that uh certain certain parties
will take advantage of the weakening
position of Russia and Syria we have
seen that by the way over the bus over
the past 18 months since the beginning
of this conflict in in Ukraine we have
seen Iran for example taking advantage
of Russia's weakening position in Syria
because Putin was forced actually to
withdraw some of his forces from Syria
because he need them in in other places
in Ukraine
we might be seeing also some
consequences in Libya in Mali in in in
Sudan but as I said before that will
also depends on how the Russian
president is going to handle all of this
uh is this going to take more time to be
to be solved by him is are we are we
witnessing a Civil War in in Russia as
some commentators have been have been
saying since this morning uh will
bruggeen be uh uh joined by other by
other by others who might be actually
feel upset by the way the Kremlin has
been or the military establishment and
Russia has been actually running this
war in Ukraine because the soul met over
the past few months actually has
affected many within the established
everybody now is questioning the ability
of the Russian military to achieve
Victory which has been promised by
President Putin at the beginning I want
to ask you briefly because we will have
about a minute left
um obviously Russia has played a
significant role in relationships in and
around the Gulf region as well do you
think that this will be enough for
countries around the gulf to start
reassessing that relationship in terms
of the the instability that you say
absolutely absolutely this is another
another another issue that we need to
address perhaps because some countries
in the Gulf they have been trying
actually to uh to diversify their
relationship over the past few years
away from the United States with Russia
with China now as the Russian president
is weakened internally and His Image is
damaged internationally they might be
reconsidering that strategy because they
might be thinking that Russia is not as
strong now we're going to have to leave
it there I'm sorry but thank you very
much